every so often there's a reason to go to  the movies here's four yes judge - yes  [Music]  you know I don't I'm fine thank you  yep we are four smart successful women I  don't need a man what is the point who  still has any interest ladies I am NOT  gonna let us become those people who  stopped living before they stopped  living I would like to introduce you to  Christian Grey this is for mature  audiences certainly sounds like us  Maya what's it been 40 years that's  impossible that wouldn't mean I was only  six this is gonna be a game-changer can  you get me some scissors I can't feel my  feet do you even remember your last date  we're talking Nixon era pretty sure he  knows you're in here  I don't care what society says about  women our age you are better at this  than you think you are the choice should  be ours does up and kiss me  only one another bottle  you